Elle est là ?
Ouais, ouais, elle est là.
Il y a eu un petit échange de regards et tout ?
Ouais, comme d'hab.
Ben, vas-y, mec.
Non, mais frère, je viens juste de m'assoir.
Je ne vais pas me lever maintenant.
Non, mais mec,
tu ne vas pas te chier dessus tous les jours.
Relève-toi !
Non, mais ce n'est pas ça, mais d'habitude,
tu me donnes un conseil un peu plus précis.
Bon, regarde.
Prends ton portefeuille, voilà.
Va la voir et tu lui lâches un truc du genre :
« Excuse-moi, ce n’est pas à toi ce portefeuille ?
Je viens de le trouver par terre. »
OK ? Là normalement elle va dire non.
Enchaine avec « je ne savais juste pas
quoi dire pour t'aborder. »
Mais fais… Marius, fais-moi confiance !
C'est insurmontable de faire ça ou pas ?
Non, ce n'est pas insurmontable.
Non, c'est bon je vais le faire.
C'est ça l'état d'esprit, frérot.
Allez, fonce.
J'ai…
Je n'ai pas parlé trop fort là ?
Non ça va, c'est un match amical.
Mais quand je joue en ligne,
on ne crie pas, d'accord ? Je dois me concentrer.
Mais comme là ça va,
ce n'est pas en ligne.
Tu as compris ou pas ?
Oui.
Ah !
Excuse-moi, c'est ton portefeuille ?
Je viens de le trouver par terre.
Ah putain ouais,
j'ai dû le laisser tomber.
Ah merci.
Attends, tu es sûre
que c'est ton portefeuille ?
Ben oui, oui, oui, c'est…
Oui.
Bon, bah, tant mieux.
Tu vas me laisser ton portefeuille
aussi facilement là ?
Mais je t'ai vu le sortir de ta poche.
J'ai vu des techniques bien pourries,
mais celle-là, on est sur un bon level !
OK OK.
Ça va merci.
Je vais récupérer mon portefeuille
et je vais vous laisser.
Oh putain, mon cœur !
Ouah !
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
C'est le vous là,
ça m'a fait sentir vieille d'un coup.
Bon, on va manger un truc ?
Ça te dit ?
J'ai une dalle.
J'ai envie d'un truc vraiment bien gras.
Ça ne te dit pas ?
Bon, tu n'as rien compris ou quoi là ?
Ben, je ne sais pas,
on se mate tout le temps.
On se lâche des sourires non-stop.
Donc, quoi ?
Donc, il y a deux options :
soit on se plait beaucoup beaucoup,
soit la deuxième option, bah,
tu comptes m'assassiner.
Et moi aussi, je compte t'assassiner.
C'est stylé,
ça peut faire un putain de scénario ça !
J'imagine bien genre...
Scarlett Johansson dans mon rôle, tu vois.
- Une nana un peu qui va…
- Carrément.
- Ouais.
- Et moi, qui joue mon rôle ?
Toi ?
Tu vois Moundir dans Koh-Lanta ?
- Ouais, je vois.
- Tu regardes ?
Lui, c'est très bien.
Il y a un truc qui se passe.
Justement deux mondes se rencontrent.
Tu vois un peu ?
Bon, je vais pisser. Tu m'attends ?
Vas-y.
- Frérot, tu es là ?
- Ouais.
Ouais.
Frère, je pars en date avec elle.
Mais non.
Mais la vie de ma mère !
Quand ça ?
Là tout de suite.
Mais non, tu es un mytho !
Je te jure.
Ouais.
Mais c'est trop chaud !
C'est ça que je savais que tu pouvais faire !
Tu l'avais en toi !
Mais oui, mon gars !
Ah, tu as pris un…
Ah, il y a hors-jeu.
Il y a hors-jeu, regarde.
Ils mettent du temps à siffler à chaque fois.
J'avoue, il n'est pas mal.
Tu as vu, hein ?
Du coup, tu manges souvent ici ?
Hum.
Enfin, en ce moment j'essaie
d'être un peu végane,
éco-responsable,
tout ça et tout.
Mais en fait après j'ai encore faim.
Du coup, je viens là.
Du coup, ça s'annule.
Complètement.
Je m'en bats les couilles, hein.
C'est ouf quand même.
Tu sais grave ce que tu veux dans la vie, toi.
- Ah bon, tu trouves ?
- Ouais.
Parce que je mange des grecs ?
Du coup, tu te dis :
« putain, celle-là ! »
Mais non, mais même avec moi,
tu as été super entreprenante.
Je ne sais pas, je trouve ça...
Je trouve ça cool.
Ben si ça se trouve, c'est qu'avec toi.
Peut-être que je ne crois pas dans le couple
et puis...
Quand je t'ai vu je me suis dit :
« ouais, peut-être que lui ouais ».
Je ne te crois pas du tout.
Toi aussi, tu sais ce que tu veux.
- Ah ouais ?
- Hum.
Tu ne le dis peut-être pas avec tes mots,
mais avec ton regard.
Ouais, j'aime bien ça.
Là, tu regrettes ton salade tomates oignons.
Non ?
Je fouette ?
Non franchement.
Par contre l'oignon,
ouais, c'est vénèr.
C'est…
Ah la honte !
Merde.
Ne t'inquiète pas.
On a tout notre temps.
Ouais.
Yes!
Oh, putain !
Allez, raconte là !
Mais attends, attends, frère.
Elle n’est pas là, Jade ?
Mec, Jade c'est mon plan cul.
Arrête de croire
qu'elle va être là à chaque fois.
- On n'est pas censés…
- Putain, tiens tes clopes.
Ça va, Marius ?
Ça va ?
Et toi ?
La pêche.
Bref, du coup, alors ?
Je t'explique.
Je ne sais même pas par où commencer.
C'était un truc de dingue.
OK, ben, photo alors.
- J'ai juste un vieux selfie qu'on a pris.
- Photo, photo, photo !
Ne commence pas à bégayer. Tu me montres.
- Mais non.
- Si.
- Mais non, mais ouech.
Non, mais toi…
Mais toi ! Mais toi, là !
Mais hey !
Mais c'est un ouf, lui !
Ça veut dire quoi ça ?
Mec, enfin... Maître, Sensei...
Ballon d'or de la chatte !
Réda parle ! C'est bien ?
Elle est bien ? Elle n'est pas bien ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Tu as géré Mila Diamond,
une actrice de cul.
Quoi ?
Normal.
- Il gère des actrices de boules.
- Tu es sûr de toi là ?
Bien sûr que je suis sûr de moi !
Mais oui bien sûr !
Je la connais par cœur !
Ça veut dire quoi ça ?
Ouais, ça veut dire quoi ça ?
Je ne comprends pas.
Ça veut dire que je…
Je me sou… Je me souviens très bien d'elle.
Non, mais tu as le droit de regarder du porno,
ça ne me dérange pas.
Mais assume.
Mais j'assume !
Ça n'a rien…
Mais à quel moment j'ai dit que
je regardais des films de cul ?
Oh là là, tu me fais chier, Réda,
quand tu fais ça là.
Assume ce n'est pas grave !
C'est une personnalité connue.
Elle était dans des reportages.
Tu sais très bien.
Tu viens de le dire.
Tu parles chinois.
Assume ! Ce n'est pas grave.
Je connais plein de personnalités.
Excuse-moi d'avoir de la culture.
Tu me fais chier. Je vais me coucher.
De Steevy Boulay à…
J'avais Fabrice.
D'ailleurs, je me rappelle
qu'il s'appelle Fabrice.
Allez viens, je te montre.
Je m'appelle Mila.
Et tu nous viens d'où ?
Je viens d'une petite ville
qui s'appelle Uzès à côté de Nîmes.
- C'est elle, c'est tellement elle.
- C'est la deuxième fois que tu viens nous voir.
Oui exact…
Attends, « step sister », ça veut dire
qu'elle fait des trucs d'inceste ?
Non « step sister »,
il n'y a pas de lien de parenté.
Ça veut dire que c'est ta sœur par alliance,
donc ça va.
Depuis quand tu es fort en anglais ?
Comment on dit « j'ai honte » en anglais ?
Comment on dit « seins » en anglais ?
« Boobs », « breasts », « titties », « tits ».
Non, mais ça va.
Tu ne te branles jamais ou quoi toi ?
C'est bon !
Si, si, je me branle.
Mais ce n'est pas une passion
comme toi.
Mais quelle passion ?
Tu me… Arrête de me juger !
On voit ce qu'il y a dans la page 2
pour voir s'il y a des trucs…
On ne voit pas ce qu'il y a en page 2.
Tu fermes frère.
C'est bon.
Mais… Mais c'est…
On n'en a même pas regardé une.
On n'en regarde pas du tout en fait.
Ferme Réda !
Merci.
En même temps,
je viens de me dire c'est relou.
Tu sors avec une meuf
et tu découvres
qu'il y a plein de photos d'elle.
Tout le monde peut voir sa chatte,
ses seins.
Comme je n'aimerais pas
que ça m'arrive.
Déso. Ouais, je n'ai pas pensé.
Tu sais qu'au fond, je m'en fous.
Comment ça ?
Je ne sais pas, frère, c'est le début.
Je ne vais pas la juger,
tu vois.
Ah ouais ?
Ben, ouais, je ne sais pas.
Après tu vois, je me demande
ce qu'elle attend de moi, tu vois.
Tu as raison de t'en foutre.
Tu ne dors pas ?
Non, j'ai faim.
Ah ben, vas-y, je fais des pâtes.
Allez !
On envoie les pâtes !
Marius,
On s'en fout de combien de personnes elle a niqué
ou je ne sais pas quoi.
Moi, je suis sûre que j'ai niqué
avec autant de mecs qu'elle.
Ah ouais ?
Non, mais à peu près.
Et puis ça n'a aucune incidence
sur mes relations de maintenant, tu vois.
Tu sais que lui, s'il entend ça,
il va chialer.
Lui là-bas ?
Lui, il s'en fout de moi.
Il te kiffe à mort.
Bon, ce n'est pas la question de toute manière.
Si tu veux te séparer de quelqu'un,
il faut que tu trouves une raison valable
dans ton présent à toi
et pas dans son passé à elle.
Dit comme ça…
Je vais la revoir, hein ?
OK regarde ce qu'on va faire.
Je vais te préparer l'appart et tout.
Jade et moi, on va au ciné.
Ah bon ?
Oui.
Enfin oui comme ça, comme ça
on lui laisse l'appart pour lui tout seul.
Comme ça, tu as l'appart que pour toi.
- C'est gentil les gars, merci.
- Normal.
Et qu'est-ce que j'allais dire.
Ouais, sois tactile.
C'est une aberration
que tu ne l'aies pas embrassée, mec.
Ah ouais ?
Ben oui, c'est une actrice de cul.
Tu sais ce qu'ils font
dans les films de cul ou pas ?
Ben oui.
Ben alors voilà, inspire-toi de ça.
Aies la même mentalité.
Il faut que tu sois aussi performant,
aussi endurant, tu vois ?
Imagine la meuf.
Elle prend moins de plaisir dans sa vie privée
que dans son travail.
Il y a un truc qui ne va pas,
tu vois ?
Tu es sûr de toi ?
Ben oui, je suis sûr.
Mec, ça marche mes conseils ou pas
quand je te…
Oui oui, ça marche, ça marche.
Ben voilà.
Dernier truc aussi.
« Avant j’étais moche dans la tess… »
« Aujourd’hui je plais à Éva Mendes ».
Voilà c'est ça.
Ça, c'est mon gars !
Voilà c'est ça, tu vois ?
C'est vrai en vrai.
Avant tu étais cheum mec.
Chez toi le premier soir et tout ?
Tu es audacieux, toi.
Normalement, je ne fais pas ça, moi.
Comment ça ?
Ben quoi, comment ça ?
Non.
Je ne sais pas. Pardon, excuse-moi.
Tu es un ouf toi.
Oui c'est évident en fait.
Je suis con.
Voilà.
- Ben bienvenue.
- Merci.
- Ben, installe-toi.
- Oui.
Tu veux boire quelque chose ?
Ouais, carrément.
J'ai de la bière ou de la bière.
Moi je prendrais plutôt une bière.
- Santé !
C'est marrant carrément l'ambiance et tout.
Ça fait film érotique un peu.
Ça va ?
Ouais ouais, ça va.
Ah non « Mission Cléopâtre »,
j'aime trop !
On va le regarder ce soir ?
Ouais, grave.
OK. Tu marques des points.
Ah.
Carrément.
En fait les…
En fait c'est mon…
Ce sont les films de mon coloc.
Je vais les récupérer.
Désolé, ouais, excuse-moi.
Il me saoule en fait.
Il me rend ouf !
Il commence à… Putain !
Ça va.
Tranquille, tranquille.
Vas-y, viens t'assoir à côté de moi.
Tu es bizarre là.
Si tu as un truc à me dire,
dis-le-moi parce que là…
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Arrête !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Comment ça je fais quoi ?
Ben, tu me fais mal.
Tu n’aimes pas ?
Mais de quoi « tu n’aimes pas » ?
Je suis censée alors que
ça fait 24 heures qu'on se connaît ?
Ben ouais, je ne sais pas.
Attends Mila, je ne comprends pas là.
Mais de quoi,
tu ne comprends pas quoi ?
Que que ma vie professionnelle et ma vie intime,
ce sont deux choses très différentes ?
C'est ça que tu ne comprends pas ?
Si tu ne comprends pas ça,
c'est juste que tu es un gros con.
Donc c'est ça, c'est ça l'explication ?
Tu es un gros con ?
Attends, Mila. Attends.
Mila, attends !
Putain.
Ouais, Mila, c'est Marius.
Je t'ai appelée cinquante fois, je sais,
mais je veux juste parler.
Rien d'autre.
Donc, accorde-moi juste ça, s'il te plaît.
Salut.
Ben là je fais quoi maintenant ?
Je suis en train d'expliquer là,
là maintenant.
Oui le matin alors que
ça fait une semaine que ça s'est fait.
Non, non ça ne marche pas comme ça.
La solution, elle est là
et toi tu ne la veux pas.
Non, on s'embrouille.
Ça va ?
Hum.
Euh, j'ai peut-être trouvé une solution.
Pour l'histoire avec Mila et tout, donc...
Normalement, s'il y a moyen que…
Eh frérot, en fait, je vais te dire un truc :
tes conseils, je n'en veux pas.
Non, non, justement,
ce ne sont pas des conseils.
C'est pour t'aider à…
- Tu veux m'aider ?
- Oui.
Toi, tu vas m'aider ?
Oui, je veux t'aider. Il y a quoi ?
Réda, aide-toi toi-même déjà.
D'accord ?
Si tu veux un conseil, commence par t'avouer
que ton plan cul, ce n'est pas un plan cul.
C'est ta copine !
Et que tu la kiffes !
D'accord ?
Tu veux te poser avec elle.
Elle n'attend que ça.
Fais ça.
Occupe-toi de toi.
Après tu t'occuperas de moi.
C'est clair ?
Ouais c'est clair.
Très clair.
Bref, je voulais dire
que je sais où est Mila.
En fait, j'ai trouvé l'adresse
d'un de ses tournages.
Donc, je te l'ai envoyée sur WhatsApp.
Voilà.
Ah oui et puis, pour Jade,
bah ouais, tu as raison, ouais.
C'est, c'est ma meuf.
C'est tellement ma meuf qu'elle m'a tèje.
Il n'y a que les couples
qui peuvent faire ça, non ?
Bien ouèje.
Oui, je peux passer à la crèche
tout à l'heure en sortant du boulot.
Ça marche.
Excuse-moi, mec.
Ouais.
Je cherche Mila.
Ah c'est toi qui passes avant moi.
Ça ne te dérange pas si j'y vais avant
parce que je commençais à être chaud là.
À être chaud ?
Ouais.
Oh putain !
Alors.
Monsieur est nouveau ?
Attention, ceci est un hold-up.
Je vous demande de mettre les mains
en l'air.
Attention ça va partir.
Pouh pouh pouh pouh !
En fait mec, je cherche juste Mila.
Tu n’es jamais venu au Far West toi.
Attention !
Ça peut partir vite !
Bill, Bill, Bill,
toujours dans les sales coups à ce que je vois.
Shérif, je vois
que votre canon est toujours impeccable.
Je vois que tu as l'œil.
Allez, fonce cow-boy.
Je m'occupe de ce sale type.
Merci, shérif.
Baisse les yeux
et prends-en de la graine.
Je trouve ça très inapproprié
de vous voir chez moi.
Je n'étais pas satisfait
de mon audition d'hier.
Alors je vous propose
d'en voir un petit peu plus.
Très bien.
Pardon, pardon.
Mila ?
Mais bordel, c'est qui ce con-là ?
Marius ?
Mais qu'est-ce…
Ce n'est pas du tout le bon moment.
Si, justement.
C'est le moment parfait.
C'est le moment parfait pour te dire que...
En fait, je m'en fous que tu fasses du porno.
Voilà.
Et oui tu as raison.
J'étais, j'étais un con.
Même le roi des cons.
Pour ne pas t'avoir traitée
pour ce que tu es vraiment à mes yeux.
C'est-à-dire la fille toute mignonne
à qui je pense tous les jours.
Et pardon,
tu es surement bien plus que ça.
Ce n'est pas ce que je veux dire.
Bref, ce que je veux dire,
c'est que ce n'est pas à moi
d'imposer ce que je crois que tu es,
mais plutôt à toi de me le faire découvrir.
Ouah.
Et c'est aussi le moment parfait pour te prouver
que ce que je dis est vrai parce que...
Parler c'est bien,
mais agir, c'est mieux.
Continuez, continuez !
Ne vous arrêtez pas ! Continuez !
Franchement,
c'est grave mignon ce que tu me dis.
On se croirait dans une comédie romantique.
Mais comme on n'est pas
dans une comédie romantique, Marius.
Comment ça ?
Ben…
Tu peux enlever ta chemise dès maintenant.
Donc en gros, elle m'a dit qu'elle ne voulait pas
se lancer dans une nouvelle relation.
- Ah ouais ?
- Ouais.
Après, ce n'est pas la fin du monde,
tu sais.
Elle veut qu'on se revoie et tout.
Mais chaque chose en son temps, tu vois.
C'est moi aussi, j'ai abusé.
J'ai fait une grande déclaration
avec des bisous à l'américaine et tout.
J'avoue que tu t'es donné là-dessus.
De ouf.
Tu sais que j'avais écrit un texte.
Voilà.
Trop. Too much mec.
Et tu sais qu'en vrai
je la comprends parce que...
Moi-même, je ne sais pas vraiment
ce que je veux, tu vois.
En vrai, c'est tellement chaud
d'être en couple.
C'est ça le truc.
C'est, c'est…
D'ailleurs, je suis désolé
pour ce que, ce que j'ai dit sur Jade.
Non tranquille, tu m'as fait ouvrir les yeux.
- Et on se voit demain soir, on va s'expliquer.
- Arrête.
Ouais, demain soir, on va se capter là,
on va essayer d'éclaircir le truc.
Je ne sais pas ce que ça va donner,
mais, tu vois.
Ça tue. Tu es saucé.
Ouais.
Non, vraiment, je ne t'en veux plus.
Là, je voulais te le dire.
Maintenant, je ne peux plus t'en vouloir
en tous cas.
Pourquoi ?
Maintenant, je ne peux plus t'en vouloir
en tous cas.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que tu t'es fait tèje aussi.
On s'est fait tèje tous les deux.
C'est ça la vérité.
Ton vieux…
- Il est dégueu en fait.
- Il est dégueulasse.
Ouais, on est d'accord.
Pourquoi on est venus là ?
Allons où on va d'habitude.
Ah là là.
Marius,
Il gère des actrices de cul, le man.
Imagine, imagine,
tu te serais posé avec elle vraiment.
Tu la présentes à ton daron,
et ton daron il dit :
« Je vous ai déjà vue quelque part ? »
« Vous me dites… »
« Non, mais vous me dites quelque chose. »
« Chérie, elle ne te dit rien ? »
« Non, pas du tout. »
« J'ai l'impression que je l'ai déjà vue. »